I have lots of edema in my legs, hands which started on the right side, but now has moved
to the left side.
I have started on occupational therapy to wear wraps and exercises, is there anything else
I can do?
I have also done some lipatic massage and some brushing.
So I have several blog posts about edema and swelling and how to help move that out of your
body.
Remember that your lymphatic system does not have a heart.
It works totally by action of the muscles.
So you need to be moving your muscles.
So if you have edema in your hands, you need to be doing some hand exercises, some arm
exercises, anything that's going to contract the muscles is going to help to move fluid
out of the tissues.
So I would work heavily on that massage, deep tissue massage on your hands and legs can
be helpful as well.
They're stroking towards your heart.
They're going to be moving fluid through the lymphatic vessels, through the lymphatic vessels,
there's typically a valve at the maximum forage as a part.
So as you move fluid through that, there's a check valve that won't go backward.
So as you get things moving, that's going to be the most helpful.
So what's the cause of the edema?
So edema can be caused from the blockage, physical blockage because the person had lymph
builds removed.
That's the most common that we talk about here because the person might have had surgery
and they had lymph builds removed so that they have less active flow edge sites for the
edema to exit.
A edema can be caused from medications.
That's probably the number one cause of a edema as different medications that a person has
been on.
A edema can be caused from chemo and radiation as well.
So just working through those things.
So you're doing some of these right things.
I would say look at the as far as other things that is possible is the swelling program,
the inflammation program on the right and make sure you're doing your ion pro wave programs
that can help with detoxing that as well.
I have lots of edema in both hands and legs actually in my torso, also not sure if this
is anything you do with the hemoglobin or not.
No, typically the edema doesn't have anything with the hemoglobin.
So two separate shoes can radiation cause edema?
Yes.
And no.
So radiation can damage blood vessels, radiation can cause leakage because it is a toxin.
You can cause leaky vessels so you can get more edema from that and especially if you have
a sight, he's in a torso, you think that could be tied to that.
Not tied to the low hemoglobin, I don't know.